je suis chez moi
tu veux faire quoi de ta vie ok j'en
sais rien et tu veux faire quel genre de
truc
tu es du potentiel je veux qu'ils me
fassent une autre vidéo ouais
maintenant un tout de suite
salut les gars merci de regarder cette
vidéo ma nièce est en admiration devant
ces gens qui me disent rien je sais
pourquoi mon existence et si lumineuse
pour qui la vie c'est ne rien dire et ne
rien faire hashtag buzine acheté
cocktail hashtag ma vie mon ananas vous
savez vous devriez peut-être bas
monsieur jacques seulement rien spéciale
vous avez du talent vous voulez être
ceux qui ont fait deux vidéos cool où
vous voulez être rien de spécial
c'est un commencement
trinquer
en garde de téléphone ou par je
m'appelle charles melton je suis en
compagnie de rien de spécial on a jeté
les vides et
ainsi d excellente idée je t'aime rien
de spécial je essentielle pour bien tu
te sens ça va devenir stade
je sais ce que tu fais d'accord tu sais
ce que je fais lui fait pas de mal ce
qu'ils faisaient
serais tu prête à montrer au monde
comprenne toi il est pas celui qui
prétend être donc succès contredit
complètement ton message tu es d'accord
tu dis aux internautes qui sens stupide
de nous regarder faut travailler parce
que tu es en train d'être emporté par
tout ça est tellement jadot lui
récupérer vos abonnés avant qu'on
reperde encore plus
prophète en son pays doit conduire ces
travaux le si on doit arrêter tout de
suite pour être méga fusion
[Musique]
est ce qu'il veut une seule chose de
vrai dans ce que tu m'a raconté
[Musique]
selon des tests
je suis un
copain
c'était génial
[Musique]